this time well protected again
gets behind the defenders for another
[Music]
touchdown
[Applause]
good protection up front that offensive
line gives them the pocket
room to step up and touchdown
[Applause]
middle of the field and nobody makes the
play trayvon's right between the hashes
and he can't defend the ball
[Music]
first down at the 28th jones gonna throw
long got water
and he's got it touchdown alabama
jalen waddle
[Applause]
[Music]
defensively they just i don't know that
they've recruited the same level
as they have offensively that's thrown
by matt jones and a nice catch by
jalen waddle throwing two touchdown two
passes rather prior to tonight
took a big shot too
[Music]
play action jones steps up right down
the middle of the field
it's touchdown the middle linebacker
is going to try to stay with him and try
to get vertical with him you just can't
make that play
it's impossible for tuff portland
[Applause]
jones goes to the end zone oh what a
catch
devonte smith touchdown alabama well he
got his 200 back in fashion didn't he
what a catch 15 for 204 and a touchdown
he steps up throws on the run and it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
edge picked up the right protection
for alabama they were ready for that
it's on waddle this time well protected
again
gets behind the defenders for another
touchdown what a throw
you cannot throw the football any better
than this
and the toughest two to hang in the
pocket
[Music]
[Applause]
jones sets gonna go deep
[Applause]
[Music]
and here's who he's looking at right
there that's safety when he does not
come off the hash
matt jones knows outside is one on one
and no one can throw a ball better than
that what up it's your boy adam lefkow
do you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report